there's no evidence i was able to find  that cannabis use makes people more  likely to commit crimes  we could imagine a scenario  where one's threshold for aggressive  behavior might be lowered by cannabis  hypothetically but that doesn't mean  that it's going to take someone not  predisposed or interested in committing  crimes and make them go and commit  crimes because they're high but of  course it's the typical double standard  because the correlation between alcohol  and crime is off the charts the  correlation between alcohol and domestic  violence is completely off the charts  compared to cannabis it's a widely  established link  and fox never talks about it because  it's not convenient